48 new officers have joined the ranks of  metro police they graduated from the  academy yesterday the grads began their  training back in april hail from eight  different states and four countries  this is very diverse very  we have i think the most diverse police  department in the united states we have  people from people came from iran the  philippines  um you name it we're there and  you know what they were there were some  of the brightest minds that i could  think about very helpful and like i said  those those people are resources to our  community and we are so glad to have  them here in our community sheriff  lombardo handed 35 men and 13 women  their badges in addition to those 48  graduates two active duty airmen at  nellis completed the academy